without getting into detail about your
personal finances after independently
producing your own special
was it worth it on the back end would
you do it again if you could go back
was a juice worth the squeeze so to
speak
100 the juice was 100
percent worth the squeeze for several
reasons
but one just climbing that mountain you
know
me hanging 10 years into comedy i wanted
something to show for it i thought it
was time for me to take that next step
in my career as
what we're doing here at hot breath is
cultivating the next generation of great
comics
i asked myself well what does a great
comic have what does a great comic do
and what a great comic has was an album
i was going to record an
album and then a listener of the podcast
actually reached out and said hey i have
a video production company let's make
this a comedy special
so it just kind of organically grew into
becoming a comedy special
it is 100 worth every
cent every experience it was just so
great to kind of
set a high goal not knowing how i'm
going to achieve it and just
incrementally working towards it it was
very rewarding
and it's now forever you know i now have
it forever when we did a q a with gary
owen
he actually talked about self-producing
some of his early comedy specials
and then just selling them out at his
live shows
and then several years later a company
actually bought those early comedy
specials from him
for like twice what he paid for them so
he actually self-produced a special
sold it on the road made back the money
on those specials
and then later down the road actually
had a company buy them
for more than he initially paid for them
to begin with
so it's just like it's just evergreen
money you know it's just that mailbox
money that just keeps rolling in
and i can say um
it was totally worth it on the back end
you don't want to get into details about
finances
but i have made my money back on it um
just in selling out the live show for
the live show i did
different tiers of tickets like from vip
all the way down
to like your general admission did a few
different levels that including
different things
and through that i was able to sell out
but also
make back about half the money just on
the show
and then through promoting it and it
just being out for a while and
through the graciousness of several of
you who have actually ordered it
it actually has made back its money now
which is so great and it was so
rewarding and really my
only goal with the special was to
complete it get out of my comfort zone
create a goal i didn't know how i was
going to
succeed at and actually work towards
making it happen
but more importantly the goal was to
show other comics that it is possible
it is possible to create your own
success just like
we're tracking with steve's um album
recording
is this is a comic who has a goal he
doesn't know how he's going to achieve
it he doesn't know what the end result's
going to be
but he has set a goal out that he wants
to record an album himself
so now we are tracking that journey and
if you heard our q
a with him today he's he's had a lot of
ups and downs with it
and that's part of the process but
a hundred percent it was completely
worth it because i was ready
this is something i can be proud of this
is something steve and i talked about
today was
if you want to record an album or do a
special just make sure it's material
that you can be proud of that
in 15 years you're still going to be
like you know what i'm i'm still proud
of those jokes
and it took me about 10 years to do that
steve's doing it almost
almost eight years now so it takes time
but uh 100 worth at pj
hey hop brother and sister if you
enjoyed this comedy tip
subscribe to this youtube channel and go
join
our facebook group to have your
questions answered live
on next week's q a